foreign
proposal my significant other has a very
Carefree sexual past it's several more
Partners than I thought she told me a
number but then later in a argument
stated that she lied about the number
and it was actually higher please don't
get engaged in a couple of weeks
yo yo yo what's up this is John with the
Dr John delone is show
greatest mental health and marriage and
parenting podcast of all time ever so
glad that you're with us thank you for
giving us your time and your attention
to things that everybody wants from you
these days
oh hey this is awesome this is awesome
it was about five months ago now I think
when it actually came out or I don't
know four months ago but we got in the
mail today check it out Nate Dogg can
you push it up there
we got our big fancy uh
100
000 subscribers YouTube award it's a
little shiny there but we got our big
fancy award we're excited if there's
anything more
appropriate that when you hit certain
Milestones a hundred thousand five
hundred thousand a million
um YouTube sends you a a an award with a
mirror on it just so you can continue to
stare at yourself right which is it's
incredible hey a hundred percent of that
is because of you
you guys hitting the Subscribe button
you guys tell your friends about this um
you men and women tuning in every a
couple times every week thank you thank
you thank you thank you I'm so grateful
my family's uh grateful uh the whole
team back here is grateful thank you so
so much
so I just I gotta say thank you all day
long but I appreciate it and we are just
getting started you're gonna see a lot
of new stuff in the new year and I can't
wait all right let's go to Marcus out in
Memphis what's up Marcus
hey Dr John how you doing good man
what's up
hey so I met the girl that I'm currently
courting uh three months ago and I'm
within two weeks of uh planned proposal
I feel hold up
wait
three months and you're already making
your move huh
yes sir so I'm
pretty embarrassed with the fact that I
haven't come to a place where I can get
out of my own head and get out of my own
way
and be accepting of the fact that my
significant other has a very carefree
and extensive sexual past okay including
uh participating in that right before we
actually got together
um so I'm hoping you can help me with
that
okay
um
talk me through it man
oh well for one um it's wave said
several more Partners than I found for
one
and two we kind of talked about it or
touched on it from a couple
conversations ago and she told me a
number but then later in a argument
stated that she lied about the number
and it was actually higher but wouldn't
tell me what the number was and so I
kind of just been mulling that over a
lot since that conversation
all right so a couple things number one
please don't get engaged in a couple of
weeks
you are a thousand miles from ready to
get married to this person okay sure
please don't please don't please don't
please don't cool
yes sir number two
um
she's not ruined and she's not less than
and she's not broken or not up to Snuff
she's somebody that you met that you
love and that you are I there's no way
you can quote unquote love in three
months there's somebody that you're
infatuated with and that you're super
interested in and that is exciting for
you and that's cool
um she's had Spirit experiences that
you wished
that she only shared with you and that's
not the case
you have two by the way homie right
yes to some degree yes yes and so now
we're into this like her number is
bigger than my number this is this is
less about her sexual partners dude and
this is more about uh
dominion and conquest and power and all
those things
is that fair
yeah I think that's fair okay you're mad
at a fantasy bro
at this idea that
this woman that you met would not have I
I don't dude it's just it's tough for me
um here's the deal you are well within
your rights
to desire somebody with little or no
sexual past you're you're ha you are I
won't take that from anybody ever okay
but if that's a big deal to you end this
today treat her with dignity and respect
and move on with your life
is that fair I mean I don't I don't
think it's not a big deal to me it's
just um it
it's just the proportion seems so crazy
but yeah I fear I mean I understand what
you're saying no you're not wrong here's
the other thing
um
you know somebody for three months and
you're already digging into some of this
some heavy intimate private stuff man
that tells me that you haven't created
an ecosystem y'all haven't had enough
time to create an ecosystem of trust
and when she when she when you told her
your number or she told you her number
she saw you wince
right she saw you be like what
and then in her mind she's like oh man
it's double that or whatever that you
know whatever it is
um there's not a there's not a platform
of trust here there's not a platform of
safety here going both ways she doesn't
feel safe to tell you to be honest with
you you don't
um you want to know but you don't really
want to know see what I'm saying
yes sir so here's here's your path
moving forward let's say no she's the
one I'm interested in creating a life
with her spend the next six months or a
year getting to know her
okay less about what activities she has
or has not participated in although that
can be an important part of of intimacy
and conversation if that's important to
you cool
um but
more so what makes you feel safe what
makes her feel loved what makes you feel
safe what makes you feel loved what are
some joint uh what's a joint vision for
your future that y'all are going to
share together that you're both going to
build together right and so if there's
judgment here the judgment is going to
be is she who she says she is
in partnering with you to create a life
together that doesn't exist yet not on
things that happen before y'all even met
does that make sense
yeah that makes perfect sense so here's
the here's the reality reality have you
had flashes of her with somebody else
yes sir there's been times yes sir okay
um are you worried that when y'all are
making out that she's thinking of
somebody else
sometimes yes sir okay cool no and I
appreciate your honesty that happens to
everybody everybody happens to you okay
here's the choice you have in that
moment
um that's your body trying to protect
you
from do I am I uh am I enough
am I as good as am I is she gonna leave
me because sex intimacy making that's
all it's all vulnerability right it's
like saying you're you are
entering into my body right you are or
I'm entering into your body like we are
super close
it's as intimate As It Gets
um
it's normal that your body and your
brain wants to know if you measure up
it's normal if your body or brain wants
to know if if you are
um worthy okay
at that moment you have a choice am I
going to meditate on these images am I
going to meditate on these worries am I
going to ruminate or am I going to
nope I'm not I'm going to replace it
with another image which is US holding
hands which is US laughing really really
hard which is her you know
throwing food at me and me cracking up
and I'd sword I can't breathe I get to
pick what images I meditate on does that
make sense and what you're going to do
is this is just slowly practicing
um changing your thoughts okay it's
practicing not dwelling on that stuff
you're a guy who likes control and
you're a guy who likes power so this is
going to be new for you
is that fair
yes okay this is you practicing not
thinking about those things is a form of
submission it's a form of vulnerability
it's a form of choosing to be healthy in
the present and moving forward and not
trying to tighten your grip on
everything that you don't like
and this is hard man
so here's my question can you do that
I
I feel like I can do that I want to do
that
do you
yes I do what's the number that will be
too high
25
why 25 not 24.
it's pretty arbitrary that's a good
question
um
I don't know exactly why 24 is not as
bad as 25.
[Laughter]
you get what I'm driving out here it's
pretty bad yes I do I know exactly what
you're doing
go back to this
she's not less than
yes
she sounds like for her for you to have
met her three months ago and you'd
already be captivated enough
to say I want to Hitch my wagons to her
for the rest of my life she has to be
pretty remarkable is that fair
yes I would absolutely agree with that
y'all share of common values moving
forward
Do you want to build a life together
yes we do okay that life can only be
built on trust and care and so I would
suggest that you reach out to her and
you say hey
I've already started this off on the
wrong foot
I had I came into this relationship with
a series of metrics
I had to have more sexual partners in
the person I was going to marry I have
to be in control I have to make these
decisions and I've realized that's a
terrible way to start a relationship so
I want to I want to do over I want to
redo
I want to get to know you
and I want to love you and I want to
create a world in our relationship where
you feel safe to tell me the truth and
yes I might be frustrated yes I might be
mad about things you did in the past
but I'm not from a judgmental thing just
from uh man I wish I'd met you 10 years
ago
I wish I'd met you 20 years ago
I only just met you now
and then understand that whatever
experiences she's had before
brought her to now
and you and only you can choose am I
going to go all in on this am I going to
choose to change my thoughts am I going
to choose to not meditate on the things
that may or may not have happened
because your fantasy world will be way
crazier that would actually happen am I
gonna not sit in Judgment of her by the
way I did the same stuff just not as
many or maybe I'm jealous whatever that
whatever your ego is telling you I'm
gonna set my ego aside as the great Ryan
holiday says ego's the enemy man ego
screws up everything
I'm just gonna look at this beautiful
woman across the table that I'm having
true affection for and say
From This Moment forward how can I love
her
recklessly and wildly until the end of
time
and how can her and I
join forces to build a an incredible new
world that's the thing that's what's
before you
if you can't do that man let her go
Let Her Go
say I just can't I'm always gonna be a
hang up for me it's always gonna be a
thing
um it's been super fun getting to know
you for three months and it's awesome
knowing that um my life's gonna be
changed because I met you but I'm gonna
move on and I'm not gonna judge you for
that dude the thing I'm going to judge
you for I think I'm gonna get pissed off
at you for is if you drag her along you
drag her through the mud you like a
puppy who poops in the living room floor
you take her nose and you rub it in
her past choices you weren't there
so you don't get a vote in what happened
in the past what you get a vote in is
who you choose to be moving forward
we'll be right back
hey everybody happy New Year deloney
here and I bet you're waiting for me to
get all sarcastic and make fun of New
Year's resolutions and okay it is funny
to me that we give each other a mulligan
for whatever we did last year because
hey it's a new year we get to start over
but I actually like New Year's and I
love New Year's resolutions intentional
resolutions can help you define what's
going to be true for you this year and a
great resolution we can all make is to
prioritize being well and that means
creating healthy practices moving your
body and here's the quickest Improvement
you can make prioritizing sleep sleep is
crucial for your mental and physical
health and good sleep starts with a
great mattress and that's why I
recommend dream cloud and right now
dream cloud is running an offer just for
my listeners get 25 off any mattress
plus 599 dollars in accessories and an
additional 50 discount when you use the
promo code John deloney it's one word so
go to dreamcloudsleep.com and enter
promo code John deloney to get your new
mattress today
all right we are back let's go to April
in Fort Wayne Indiana you know what's up
April
hi Dr John I don't know why I just did
that uh West Texas accent in Fort Wayne
Indiana what is the accent of Fort Wayne
Indiana
I feel like we have no accent
incredible all right so what's up April
how do I support my son and his choice
to have or not have a relationship with
his bio dad's family after his dad
committed suicide
whoa whoa whoa
cheers
yeah walking me through this that was I
didn't see that curveball coming
okay sorry no I think it's hey you you
get a prize it's it's rare that I'm like
wait what I thought you were gonna say
he's dipping again or something so no
this sounds uh very much a left turn
okay so
um your son's dad took his died by
Suicide right were y'all married
no okay so we had his dad and I had him
when we were in high school okay and his
dad was really involved for like the
first year okay and then we didn't see
him again
oh okay until I went to the funeral so
geez okay how long ago did he pass away
so it's been a few years good so it's
kind of been like a build up I guess to
this point
um he killed himself two days before my
son turned five
today is the fourth birthday
and of course as soon as he died then
his family came out of the woodwork
because he hadn't seen them either and
they really wanted to have a
relationship with my son of course
and
I was young so I kind of just took the
advice I was given from people that were
well-meaning but they had never been
through this sure
um which is kind of why I'm calling you
because I need really good advice sure
for maybe an outsider my son is now 13.
so so what advice did you follow did you
connect him with his extended family or
did you Circle okay started we started
out we came up with they wanted him
every other holiday and we'd kind of
work out in between that was really good
for a few years and he didn't know them
no he did not because that was part of
the juggle too is trying to introduce
him like we kind of went slowly
introducing him it was hard to explain I
had
I had started dating someone else okay
so when he was two we started dating
when we turned three we moved in
together but as far back as he can
remember that is his dad
the person that you do you still are you
still with that person now yeah okay
we've been married 10 years okay so
that's his dad
yeah that is his dad he has no memories
at all of his dad which I think is kind
of one thing that's leading us to the
point we are right now
um which is his bio family has slowly
started to kind of back out
um and he is also slowly backing out
but it's Christmas this week and so
they're calling now because they would
like to see him for Christmas Even
though they haven't seen him all year
yeah and have only talked to him a few
times
he does not want to go he has been very
um forward with me we have a really good
relationship with him and I probably
because I was so young and we really
grew up together but he's very open we
have a very good him and I line of
communication he feels comfortable
telling me exactly how he feels
um so I know his big issue
um on why he chooses I just don't know
if I should be like hey you really need
to go forward with this or if it's okay
to say hey it's fine take a break from
that relationship for a while absolutely
yes
um here's what's happening right like
when he's six seven eight
going to spend time young kids
especially not all of them because
people can be listening to me like not
my kid kids are great when they have to
at putting on a brave face and smiling
and also the novelty of new adults who
are kind and doting and loving can be
um can really fill a kid's sales okay
and give them some some real propulsion
forward my daughter
um uh Josephine she she
had a babysitter a few a few months ago
and the babysitter had to go home and
check on some things well at home was
the babysitter's mom and the
babysitter's grandmother they all ended
up going out to a park together and at
the end of the day that grandmother said
well it looks like I just got myself a
new granddaughter and Josephine my
daughter is Mayhem she's hilarious to be
around and if she's if you're in her
good graces she is like a magnet she's
incredible
she has retold that story a thousand
times
right of how this these these other
adults took her in and were like you're
I got a new Grant right she's told that
story over and over and over I tell you
that to tell you the age that we're
talking about here the developmental
stages five six seven eight
they're wired for doting they're wired
for just smiling and scanning and
they're wired for adults who say you're
welcome here
when they get to be 11 12 13 they begin
to understand what's actually going on
okay they can also begin to sense
oh you are using me because you're not
okay
and there's one thing he has expressed
to me he says I feel like the
relationship is
contingent on their grief yes and I hate
that he feels that way well he's 12 and
13 and 14 and 15 year olds are 16 year
olds
and I I think we could go back on in
evolutionary psychology and kind of work
through it but they are their their
sonar is incredibly precise they feel it
that's why kids when they're responsible
for their parents like don't make dad
mad don't they they they create entire
new Pathways for their life that ends up
in in adulthood right so your son is
very on to it he gets it he also wants
to honor you because y'all are close and
he also doesn't want to be a jerk is
that fair
right so he feels stuck
um here's another thing he's doing right
now
his biological he's going to start
asking as he goes through puberty and
Beyond he's going to start asking who am
I in a profound way
he is going to have to come to terms
with half of him chose to die
right which we've kind of a little bit
are getting into that you can talk about
it all day long this is something that
will come from the inside out
okay and by the way for those people who
are into who are suicidologists who are
into studying this I understand that
what I just said him choosing to die is
a controversial I don't mean for it to
be that way but for my 13 year old my
dad made a decision to not he'd rather
be gone than with me he'd rather be gone
than know me any further because 13 year
olds are very like eye Centric so
he's got to make he's got to come to
terms with that and he's also has to
come to terms with practicing autonomy
the world ripped his dad from him
at the age of five and he his father the
guy he's with there I mean I'm sorry his
dad every day that he's with he loves
and all that but that lingering who am I
and I want to get to know myself is gone
and the world took that from him and so
he's feels powerless is what I'm getting
at and so him practicing I have some
tiny bit of autonomy I get to choose but
my body says no I get to honor that and
you as his mom play
Cornerstone role in teaching him nope
your body is correct and we're going to
honor what that body says now this is a
this is a
this is a tightrope to walk because
sometimes his bodies can make I don't
want to go to school and I don't want to
go to work and I don't you know I want
to smoke weed and then you're gonna be
like I don't really care what your body
says you're not doing that right so
there's going to be a balance here but
when it comes to relationships I would
really trust his intuition right now
this means I know a really hard
conversation between you and your
your his his grandparents
yeah and let's be honest
he is their last shred of their lost son
I get it
I totally get it
and I get the devastation and the
Heartbreak so
um here's what we're what we're doing
anytime there's a tragedy like this
you instantly shift from a four to five
year game hope he goes to a good college
and I hope he starts dating somebody
nice you immediately shift from a four
to five year game to a 25-year game
I hope that he is a functioning loving
productive human being at the age of 45
now after his dad died by Suicide that's
the transition we're making okay we're
playing a long long game what does that
mean that means we're gonna have a lot
of Grace because he's gonna really
struggle when he's 15 16 17. we're just
gonna know that going in it's gonna be
tough he's gonna be feeling untethered
and you're going to be thinking he's got
a dad here that loves him who's been
here since he was a you're right and he
has a body saying where's my home
where's my home base and only half of it
is there right so he's going to be
flopping around the wind like a kite
we're playing a 25-year game
we're not playing a
are you in the Key Club are you in
Spanish club too we're playing a longer
game than that that's the conversation
you have with grandparents if we force
this now at 13 14 and 15 the moment he
turns 18
you will he'll be a ghost to them
right and so what would be better for
them is to all record him a message to
write him letters to give him things
tangibly that he can hold not just
crappy gifts but actual connect
connections and give those to him for
Christmas and
um and I'm even okay with this
um not okay with lying but I'm okay with
you taking her on the chin this year and
saying hey it's just not a good year for
our family when it comes to travel when
it comes to connectivity it's just not a
good year for us but we will do what we
can in the coming year to see if there's
an opportunity to make this thing work
okay can I ask you one more question of
course
okay so one thing that he pointed out to
me is that he really doesn't like and I
don't know if I should be the one to
express this to them or if I should wait
on him to come into it on his own
because I feel like maybe it'll change
but at this point he says it really
bothers him when he goes to see them or
talk to them and anything that happens
they say oh your dad was just like that
um yeah she says to me like he feels no
connection because he has zero memory of
him right and so he's like it's like
they're telling me I'm like a stranger
and it makes them uncomfortable
absolutely I don't want him to be
uncomfortable so I feel like I should
say something but I don't know how to do
it in a way that's like loving and not
insulting to them yeah I
um
that's gonna switch in two three four
five years it's going to be the deepest
honor in his life to know that there was
somebody else that walked steps before
him
okay and so this is it may be something
you mentioned if you're having this
conversation about hey this just isn't a
good year
um for us or little Charlie's not doing
well this year
um or he's we're gonna just circle up
and have a really intimate quiet family
Christmas
um and so this isn't going to be a good
time
if that if if somebody in that family
were to say who you're talking to
you yeah we understand it's super hard
on that little boy and we miss him and
but I understand that he's 13 and this
is just a tough time for him
that might be a good moment to say hey
one thing to keep in mind when he does
come around again
um references to his dad you walk like
him you laugh just like him that make
him really uncomfortable and I want him
to have a relationship with you all down
the road
um [ __ ] want y'all to know that he's
mentioned that that might be a good
moment for that otherwise
that's a thing between y'all too and if
he was my son and he was 14 and he'd
made the decision I want to go do
Christmas with my with my one day with
the extended family the people I share
genetics with down the line
I would let him know hey people are
going to make comments about how you
laugh like your dad or your your birth
father they're gonna make just just know
that just know that that's their way of
telling you that they love you and that
they are glad that you're there and you
you see what I'm saying it's a way of
teaching him hey they're not trying to
be ugly they're just trying to honor the
loss of the person that they loved but
I think it's important for everybody to
note that's not his job his job isn't to
heal everybody else
he's a 13 year old boy he can't carry
the grief of his extended family it's
their job to do their healing on their
own and then hopefully down the road
there's a way that people can we can
honor everybody can honor each other
right
um
and I guess here's a good point to say
if he never comes around to them I
as he doesn't have to as far as I'm
concerned
if next year and the year after and the
year after he just does not have a
connection and does not want to go spend
a holiday with strangers I'm okay with
that I'm going to let him have that
autonomy
there will come a day when he wants to
know about his Heritage and he wants to
know where he's from and we want to
preserve those relationships the trail
the path to those relationships so that
when he comes a knocking he has a safe
place to go he's interested in going not
he decides I'm gonna bury my Heritage
because I don't want to know because I
hate those people
that's a recipe for all kinds of
psychological dysfunction down the road
so you're good good good Mom God
Almighty he's lucky to have you and I'm
so sorry about your loss
um I know even even though it's been a
long time holidays just bring all that
stuff up
have the hard conversation with
the other family
tell your son that you honor his wishes
and that when his gut tells him that you
want to um teach him that his body is
telling him the truth and the body says
no let's listen to it
but he still has to go to school and
make his bed right thank you so much for
the call we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from this episode sponsor better help
hey look there's a lot of things we
don't get to choose on this wild ride
called life right the neighbor's kid
learning to play Trombone weird things
trending on the tick tocks or whatever
that is we don't get to choose the
weather but when you realize how much
you do have a choice in it's so
empowering check this out you get to
decide who you want to be I get to ask
myself the question who do I want to be
you get to choose who speaks into your
life and you get to choose to pursue
meaningful relationships this is
life-changing stuff but I'll be honest
it's not easy these are new skills that
we all have to learn and therapy is a
great place to practice these new skills
and that's why I love better help better
help is Affordable online therapy that
can match you with a therapist quickly
and it lets you switch any time to make
sure it's the right fit and just like
in-person therapy it can help equip you
with the tools you need to work towards
being who you want to be because you
don't just have to let life happen to
you you can take it head on so visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right let's go to Marie in Stevens
Point Wisconsin what's up Marie
hey Dr Jim thanks uh for having me on
your show of course what's happening
okay so next summer I am getting married
and gross do you like him
yes all right good for you hey I'm
excited for you good for you
thank you so my parents have
fun that's uh specifically going to be
used for the wedding and then anything
left over they said we could use
straight towards our house down payment
so are y'all loping and just taking all
the money and dumping it on your house
uh no we're having a wedding
um but my parents are kind of
insistent that we have like a big
expensive party and we don't really want
that and I'm having a hard time
communicating with them to have us both
be on the same page
all right I'm going to give you my
opinion this doesn't represent the
people I work for this doesn't represent
my wife my family represents just me
okay
okay is that cool
yeah
if you are accepting their money you're
also accepting what that money is buying
them which is the choice to run your
wedding
I don't like it for you it's it makes me
Oogie
but they have purchased their influence
their opinions their choices on how you
are going to celebrate your marriage
because they're paying for it
and so either
y'all can make peace with it and just
say cool y'all are paying for it let's
blow it out
or you can have a really uncomfortable
conversation that goes something like we
value having
um a paid off house more than we have
one big wild party
so we want this to be as small as
possible so that we can put the rest of
the money towards our house and if they
say that's that's are they have they let
me ask have they said like well your
guests are really gonna have they said
that
well they keep going back and forth
saying that they had a small wedding so
we're allowed to have whatever we want
and that the day is about the two of us
so we're gonna make all the decisions
and then when we tell them something
they say that's tacky and we shouldn't
be skipping out our guests because they
have to travel and like pay for their
hotel so we should be I love it giving
them the best dessert or whatever I love
it but then they turn around and say but
it's your wedding so it's do you guys
get to choose
okay just move forward knowing you don't
get a choice
okay not even a little one
um at some point you can sit down with
with
um is this your parents
yes you can sit down with your mom or
dad and say how about this you all
designed the wedding that you all want
to pay for and we will we will show up
and be ready to party
okay
um
and that will probably be uncomfortable
or they might say oh thank God what
would they say if you sat down and said
hey we've we've just had an epiphany I
don't want to put any more tacky ideas
in front of you I don't want to put any
more things that you think are going to
be disrespectful to the guests so how
about this you all plan an amazing
wedding y'all are paying for it you plan
an amazing wedding and we will be there
and we will we will dance the night away
what would you what would they do if you
said that
um I think they'd be happy about that
but they also don't want to plan the
whole thing either because we've already
like picked out most of the stuff and
now it's just kind of coming down to
like
extra bands and like wedding favors and
what dessert people to go with Ed is the
money worth it
um I mean how much we talking technique
uh like a hundred okay
how much are you spending on this week
yeah
also my Integrity for a hundred thousand
dollars let's be clear
um not really but kind of
how much is this wedding gonna cost
uh right now on my budget sheet it's
like 35
okay
and which part of it are you feeling
uncomfortable with as though it violates
some sort of core principle in you
spending so much money on one day it's
not your money so why does it bother you
um I don't
I don't know I guess it just seems like
a really big number it's a huge number
is there a part of this that you have an
identity of your of yourself a story you
tell yourself that those type of
weddings are for those type of women
or those type of weddings are for
I'm I'm I'm not that I am
I'm something else there's a great
Theologian that said people can often be
as proud of the things they don't have
as those as other people are of the
things they do have
that's that's a that's a thing I fall
into is that is that what you're
struggling with or is this just purely
like no this is insane this is one night
it's not worth thirty five thousand
dollars
it's a mix of both okay it's definitely
both
okay
because I don't want to paint your
picture your parents in a bad light it
sounds like they're they're willing to
put
55 or 65 000 down on your house for you
which by the way they're gonna have an
opinion about which house you buy and
where you buy it and what kind of the
decorations you have in your house and
what's Tech you're not there comes a
moment in your young marriage and you
have to decide they've got a lot of
money and we don't want it
or I'm just trying to decide like where
do I put my foot down on this
where do you want to put it down
because the uh the house buying process
will be exactly the same
and then when they start a college fund
for your first child it will be the
exact same
this is for wherever he or she wants to
go to college if whatever well he wants
to actually go to a trade school well
yeah this is we this scene he's go
Stanford
right this is gonna happen Forever This
has probably happened your whole life is
that fair
yeah yeah
so you eat I mean the two choices before
you that I could see is you make peace
with it or you say no thank you
all right what do you what are you gonna
do
foreign
relationship with my parents so but I
see here's where that's oh Marie don't
do that don't do that don't do that you
know what you just did
you took their relational dysfunction
and made it your job to fix it
I don't want to have a bad relationship
with them so I guess I will fill in the
blank just take their money or I'll just
have the wedding they want me to have
I'll just buy whatever house they tell
me I need to buy or I'll just
start from the from the completely other
end for the first time in your life
Marie you've never done this for the
first time do it
say what kind of Life do I want to have
what kind of Life do I want to have
what is important to me and my fiance
what kind of home do we want to have
what kind of party do we want to have
celebrating our marriage
and if that means a low-key party that
has really expensive desserts all right
or no it's a big deal to me that we
don't have expensive desserts I want to
donate that money to a local uh Food
Bank Great tell your parents
but don't do things don't continue to
come you've been doing this your whole
life
and now you're making a new home this is
what family tree changing family tree
looks like
I'm not going to use my money to get to
to buy influence over my kids lives I'm
gonna love them unconditionally
see what I'm saying
is that some bonkers
no
is this not even possible like something
you're even interested in or not really
I mean it's um I mean it sounds possible
you don't sound like it one bit you
know
I'm just like scared to talk to them
here's your homework assignment you
ready
yes okay tonight I want you to sit down
um with a piece of paper
not on a computer either with a piece of
paper you know what I don't care if it's
on a computer I don't care just on your
cell phone
and I want you to
write down for the first time my dream
wedding here's what it would look like
and I want you to write down my dream
home here's what it would look like
and then in the next 48 to 72 hours I
want you to take your fiance out for
some sort of meal
with a blank sheet of paper and I want
you to say hey we're building a new
world together a new life
what do we want this to look like
and I want you to be super specific we
want to have a home like this in this
neighborhood and we want to have this
many kids and of course all this will
change
but you're practicing something you've
never done which is asking yourself what
do I actually want
because right now you're a puppet for
your parents fantasy and I'm not
painting them in a bad light they've
done really well for themselves
financially they've planned ahead
and they've planned ahead with the
purpose of our kids we'll have weddings
that look like this and our kids will
have homes that look like that
our kids will drive cars that look like
this our kids will have
their own children our grandkids that
will go to schools like this and what
you are is a pawn in somebody else's
life
and man being a pawn in somebody else's
life with that kind of resources you get
to drive nice cars and your kids get to
uh
go to cool schools and go on great
family vacations
and you also got in the backyard with a
shovel and dig a deep hole and bury
yourself in the process
I don't think it has to be either or I
think there can be a great conversation
about hey Bunch I'll go ahead and just
decide what we're having for dessert
because it seems to be really important
to you and it's not to us
or hey we've just had a long hard
conversation we're gonna just return the
money and we're gonna figure it out on
our own because we want to have our kind
of wedding we want to have our kind of
home and I think it's important that we
start from scratch here put that into a
college fund for the grandkids and maybe
uh maybe they'll use that one day
or just make peace man just get the
fancy desserts
and move on with your day get a couple
of get like 40 or 50 bags of beef and
cheddar from Arby's
or Whoppers with cheese that would be
incredible what a flex that would be
like here's your fancy desserts and
there's the Arby's and Burger King table
that would be dope actually
it's called compromise right thank you
for the call we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back
um
today's song of the day is from a band
I've never heard of I'm ashamed to say
they're all kind of making fun of me
back in the booth I need to quit
listening to my old
metal CDs I guess as Kelly said they
have what bouncy little bass lines
bouncy little bass lines
Hunter talking about some guys in the
club but
songs from a band called The 1975. the
song's called human too
considering me looking through you
thinking it was something I used to do I
thought I'd done anger I thought I'd
done shame but I've always been the same
well don't you know that I'm human too
you know that you're a human too darling
that's what humans do so tell me you're
a human
don't you know that I'm a human too
it sounds like a robot like at the end
of a Disney movie don't you know I'm a
human too
[Music]
yes I do yes I do we'll see you soon
[Music]